you know those days when it's cold
outside and you wanna stay indoors do
nothing just watch TV series all today
is not one of those days because I want
to do a video request for you guys now
if you're new here to my channel
consider subscribing and click the
notification about so you won't miss any
of the next videos now some of you have
asked me hey Daniel what is the best
body wash for men so that's what I'm
gonna talk about in this video so let's
get to it I have a dream first up is the
every man-jack
body wash now this is a high quality yet
affordable body wash that is green so in
other words it has no GMOs or dyes so
they use natural plant-based ingredients
it is great for sensitive skin and it
doesn't make your skin dry also get a
lot of soap for the money if you know
what I mean let's move on to the next
one
[Music]
the super hydrating cleanser from era
organics now this is one of the best
body washes out there on the market why
because it has no cheap chemicals or
toxins that strip your skin it is an
organic body wash that is safe and very
effective so inside it you get a
chamomile coconut oil shea butter jojoba
oil avocado oil and rosehip seed oil
this body wash is like a powerhouse for
good healthy skin American Crew men
classic through in one now if you're a
guide and you don't want to use too many
products then this is the body wash for
you not only is it a good body wash but
it can also be used to wash your hair it
will leave your hair and skin
revitalized and healthy-looking and this
is really actually a perfect body wash
especially if you're on the road a lot
next up is Duff clean comfort not Duff
they don't need any introduction right
you guys know them as well from all the
cheap products are there dove is
probably one of the best because they
have a good balance of price and quality
so it's good and hydrating your skin and
leaving you feeling clean and fresh
all right we're the last one and hey
just so you know I added the links of
all the body washes for you in a video
description so it's easier for you to go
and check them out your own research
check out the customer reviews on them
as well so the last one the best body
wash is the tea tree oil foot and body
wash it's from purely North West it's
got an extra strength formula that has a
very strong defense against many skin
concerns that soothes its skin
it's got aloe vera Atlantic sea scalp
vitamins A B 1 B 2 C D and E it also has
a blend of tea tree eucalyptus oregano
peppermint and other oils that leaves
your skin soft and healthy just some
last advice listen up try the shower
before you get into bed yes most guys
out there like to shower in the morning
you can do that as well yeah it's a good
idea to two times a day but if you don't
shower at nighttime then you get into
bed dirty so what happens to your bed
night after night after night
yes it's dirty and then you go and sleep
in that dirty bed night after night
especially if you struggle with pimples
or all kinds of stuff you're just making
yourself very and you're eating that
kind of dirt the whole night think about
that so after if your days your bed is
actually bigger than you are anyway if
you liked the video give it a thumbs up
to subscribe and I'll see you in the
next video
Cheers
[Music]
you
[Music]